I mentioned before that we rationalize the denominator so we can make a better
approximation for our answer. We can use the square root of 10 divided by 5 to
help us approximate the answer for this expression. I don't know what it really
means to divide by root 5. But I can approximate this by dividing by 5. We know
the square root of 9 equals 3, so the square root of 10 is just a little bit
more than 3. We're going to approximate it though and just use 3. So root 10
divided by 5 is about 3 5th or 6 10th. If we would had left this expression as
it was, we would have had to divide by a non-terminating decimal. Dividing by
the square root of 5 is much more challenging than doing this approximation. As
we work through this unit, we'll be taking denominators that contain radicals
and changing them into integers or other expressions that don't contain
radicals. For square roots, this is pretty simple. We can just multiply the
numerator and denominator. By the exact radical that appears in the
denominator. Then we just multiply our radicals together and simplify if
possible.